[Musica]
se mi aveste chiesto qualche anno fa che
cos'è per me la cultura gli avrei
portato ad una mostra ma non per vedere
le opere gli avrei portato a vedere le
cornici perché le cornici sono quella
cosa che ci dicono
cos'è un opera d'arte all'interno della
mostra ci dicono nostro occhio dove
guardare senza di esse saremmo persi
perché tutto può essere un'opera d'arte
due scuole praticamente contrapposte e
l'una con l'altra
ma se siete giovani non lo sapevo ma
facciamo soltanto ci stanno ma se non
sai neanche chi è ma questo è gravissimo
e mia nonna mia casa due uguali pensavo
che fosse
ma questo non è una sedia comune questo
è il concetto di serialità
sì perché la cultura per me è sempre
stata l'insieme di queste cornici quella
cosa a cui ancorarci per dare un
significato un punto di riferimento
quella rete che per noi significa
prendere la decisione giusta fare la
scelta giusta dare un significato e un
senso alle nostre azioni
questo che l'avrei detto fino a qualche
anno fa sei anni fa prima di nascere una
barba intensa per essere alle elementari
e cosa facevo prima di nascere
essenzialmente facevo questo volavo era
un ballerino professionista di
breakdance e all'epoca pensavo che
quello sarebbe stato il mio lavoro per
molto tempo
l'università il lavoro serio teheran
tutti i piani b e non solo non sapevo
che sarebbero presto diventati piani a
non sapevo che da lì a 6 anni avrei
vissuto svezia russia negli stati uniti
e non sapevo che quel giorno sarà in
atto di nuovo quel giorno mi trovavo in
uno starbucks a berlino il giorno prima
c'era stato un grandissimo contest di
breakdance la crew era far pagliata per
lo starbucks era di ottimo umore mentre
lui no lui era in disparte in ombra lui
che quel contest ieri l'aveva vinto era
entrato nel cerchio in un secondo
l'infortunio gli avversari in genere non
poteva non chiederglielo perché come fai
dove trovi questa energia da dove viene
fuori come fai a trasformarti in ricordo
uscire dalla penombra coi suoi occhi
ardere dirmi questa è la mia vita fra io
questo voglio fare io questo sono e
torno avere un cappuccino e lo per ombra
come se fosse così scontato come se
fosse così per tutti
e ricordo di tornare da quel viaggio a
piangere nel bagno dell'aereo di rainer
perché non amavo ballare come lo amava
lui perché non amavo niente così tanto
da rendere inutile tutto il resto niente
così tanto da trasformarmi quel giorno
sono andato perché da quel momento cerca
di dare una risposta a queste domande
ovviamente sono tornato sui libri ma
avevo un problema
non so se vi capita leggevo magari 300
pagine di libro e poi dopo due mesi a
raccontare i miei amici mi ricordavo
siano tra i concetti poi scopro di non
essere l'unico perché noi in realtà
tratteniamo fino al 10 per cento delle
informazioni della prima lettura
ma c'è un trucco basta cambiare
prospettiva perché se noi invece
leggiamo con l'obiettivo di insegnare
agli altri o di fare nella pratica
ritiriamo fino al 90 per cento di queste
informazioni
e così è stato ho aperto un blog un
piccolo gesto
cosa che però mi ha cambiato
completamente la prospettiva mi ha fatto
leggere per poter scrivere e mi ha fatto
conoscere la storia di john la storia
che ha cambiato il modo in cui vedevo le
cornici vorrei che immagina stessi
momento ci troviamo nel 1187
saladino un generale musulmano appena ha
saltato gerusalemme e l'ha conquistata e
il papa in tutta risposta indice la
terza crociata per conquistare la terra
santa
immaginate john un nobile inglese che
lascia la sua casa per seguire la
crociata
lui credeva fortemente che se fosse
morto durante questa crociata sarebbe
finito in paradiso tra le schiere
celesti dove avrebbe potuto di una
eterna beatitudine lo sapeva perché suo
nonno mi raccontava prendendo la sua
spada arrugginita che oggi era sopra
nella volta del salone ti raccontava le
gesta della seconda crociata i
menestrelli cavalieri del castello tutti
così quando decide di partire e il papa
promette ai giovani salvezza eterna
giovani come john
lo dice i suoi genitori ha così
orgoglioso sono pronto ma quando arriva
scopre una cosa che lo lascia molto
stupito perché anche i saraceni
credevano quello in cui credeva john si
facevano un po confusione perché
credevano che lui fosse l'infedele e che
loro sarebbero nati in paradiso ma il
principio lo condivideva se combatti
nome del tuo credo finisce in paradiso
ora potrà anche essere che i suoi
genitori fossero in errore che il barone
dall'altra parte del fiume fosse in
errore che il parroco ma anche i
saraceni dall'altra parte del mondo
no se combatti nome del tuo credo va in
paradiso il castello brucia fino alle
fondamente non c'è più traccia di john
la supposta c'è un centro commerciale
immaginate ragazzi annoiati sugli
smartphone quando a un certo punto uno
squarcio temporale fa apparire john lee
nella vuole dire ragazzi sono pronto sto
andando a combattere gli infedeli in
terrasanta non ha alcun significato oggi
al contrario se uno di questi si
riunisse insieme a un'operazione
benefica andasse a combattere scusatemi
a difendere i diritti dei rifugiati e
non combattere quello sì che sarebbe un
errore
ma questo non ha alcun significato per
giorno e così funziona la storia tessere
una fitta rete di significato
la gente ci crede con sincerità con
passione ma presto tardi questa rete si
disfa e ciò che a cui davamo un senso
prima non ha più senso dopo oggi
combattere pensano di andare in paradiso
non ha alcun senso
le guerre mondiali non ha alcun senso i
disastri nucleari non hanno alcun senso
tra cent'anni quello che facciamo noi
oggi non avrà alcun senso magari lavora
qui sto dedicando la mia vita non avrà
alcun senso
devo ammetterlo lì è partito un po un
immobilismo relativista ed avrà cosa
devo fare
fino a che non mi sono resa conto che
c'era un punto in comune in tutto questo
e quel punto in comune era quello che
spostava le cornici quel punto in comune
era siede saraceni che di john e sarà
oggi come 300 anni ed erano le storie
delle persone
avevo capito che per liberarmi da questo
immobilismo dovevo raccontare le loro
storie ma mi serviva un media mi serviva
un mezzo un blog un video
pensate che nelle introduzioni
tecnologiche c'è un numero di
riferimento che misura quante persone
stanno utilizzando questa tecnologia e
da 50 milioni
il telefono da quando fu inventato
impiego circa 75 anni per raggiungere
quel numero la radio negli anni 20 38
meta la tv negli anni 50 13 meno della
metà sapete quanto impiega a raggiungere
19 50 milioni di persone l'app pokémon
lasciata qualche anno fa per smartphone
impiega 19 giorni come facevo a
raccontare una storia un media così
intimo qualcosa di così pregnante che
rimane in questo contesto di
sovrapposizione dei media in queste
volver si continua
io ho scelto il podcast il podcast è un
contenuto audio e ha soltanto la voce
per questo è un media intimo per questo
ho l'impressione che parli sempre
soltanto a me non è come la radio che
dice voi ascoltatori è una storia che io
sento solo nelle mie orecchie ed è una
storia che noi in realtà sentiamo da
sempre la voce il suono l'audio ci
arrivano sin da quando siamo bambini sin
dalla pancia della mamma loro creano le
nostre emozioni
la voce come strumento per dare voce ed
è lì che ho scoperto il podcast è lì che
ho iniziato a raccontare la mia storia è
lì che ho cambiato lavoro cambiato città
raccontando le storie delle persone
facendo nella mia nuova vita perché le
nostre storie le vostre storie sono la
cultura di domani e possono cambiare la
passano influenzarla possono costruirla
le nostre storie le vostre storie con
loro intrecciarsi coloro turbinio di
eventi ognuna dal suo punto di vista
crea la cultura del futuro
ed è con questo che voglio lasciarvi con
un augurio la cultura del futuro è
scritta nelle vostre storie iniziato a
raccontarle
[Applauso]
[Musica]